one thing you may have noticed first in
this trailer is that they never show off
penny wise his face in full it's always
instructed by something but after going
through frame by frame
I found a subliminal message that plays
for 1/12 of a second so stick around if
you want to see that this opening scene
with the boat seems to show that this
will be super faithful to the source
material this box of tissues shows us
that bill is sick when he makes the boat
these curtains tell us that they're in
the 50s there seems to be a pad and
pencil down Bill's bed
perhaps a nod to the fact that bill
grows up to be a writer in the book he
also seems quite interested in astronomy
though I'm not sure what to make of that
let me know your interpretation in the
common as Georgie is playing with the
boat we see that the streets of Derry
seem to be covered with these tents
which are blocked off by Public Works it
looks like they may have been used to
cover up sewage caps in the street which
may be a result of it with sandbags all
around the base of these tents it seems
that they don't want anything getting in
or out glad to see this scene in here I
know all too many people who refuse to
walk near sewer grates because of this
part it's obviously dark in there but it
seems Pennywise may not have his
signature balloons there are two big red
arrows on the ground pointed at this
monument here we see a woman putting up
missing posters for Patrick [ __ ] stutter
Patrick is one of the bullies and Henry
Bowers gangs who terrorizes the losers
Club in the 1990 TV mini-series he's
basically just a minor character but in
the book he's probably the most
disturbing human character of all I'm
gonna steer clear of spoilers but if
you've read the book you know that
things are about to get dark also look
how many staples there are in this post
just think about all the missing kids in
this town that have already been given
up on this is obviously the library
scene but as I recall the scene took
place when they were adults not kids
it was also Ritchie you see penny wise
in the balloons in the library in the
miniseries at least judging by his
weight I'd say that this character is
supposed to be Ben as a disclaimer there
may be things that I'm forgetting from
the book and please drop me a comment if
that's the case but the point is that
throughout the entirety of this trailer
we seem to only see the characters of
kid leaving me to believe that the adult
portions of the story may be cut out or
Warner Brothers is planning to do a
sequel look at this shirt he's wearing
this is clearly a reference to Stephen
King's book Christine the one with the
killer cars
this house is probably 29 niebolt Street
a rundown house in the book with a kids
encounter it in some of its other forms
in fact it's basically confirmed a few
moments later when we see niebolt Street
on the map of the sewer system
speaking of which we can also see that a
sewage line runs through the cemetery
which means we may get a new adaptation
of the grave digging scene so it take
your pick but a billy boy except for the
one on the end that one's already taken
sorry it's not really clear what's going
on here but they're basically using
their projector to display a map of
Derry onto the map of the sewer lines so
they can see exactly where the sewers
line up with actual locations in the
town here we see one of the kids taking
a puff of his inhaler which means that
his character is probably eddying the
asthmatic of the group in the book the
inhaler becomes a weapon used against
Pennywise and its presence here suggests
that may still be the case earlier in
the trailer we see them putting slides
in the projector this slide clearly says
made in USA then later on it shows a
slide popping out and if you look
closely it says made in Canada Beverly
wears a key around her neck and Ben has
solar systems on his shirt a possible
connection to the planet in Bill's room
for the rest of the trailer from this
point on they cut to these two frames of
the blank wall upon which they were
showing the projection in between shots
if you are wondering what that was if
you look closely at penny wises
reflection right here you'll notice that
its eyes don't seem to reflect in the
water which is pretty creepy if you ask
me you'll also notice the washer and
dryer right here which means they aren't
in the sewer in this scene they're in
somebody's flooded basement or something
and finally the last shot of the trailer
we see this wall again for 1/12 of a
second and the projector is now showing
our first totally unobstructed view of
penny wises face and that's it
pun intended if you're excited for this
movie then give this video a like and if
you're new here on the channel my name
is Susie and I direct horror films and
write horror stories people have told me
that I'm like the Stephen King of the
YouTube generation so if that sounds
interesting to you be sure to subscribe
to see these worlds for new Horrors
every other week ring that death bell
for notifications and I'll see you in
the next one assuming we
both survived